[Música]
[Aplausos]
comer hamburguesas sin matar animales
y fabricar medicamentos específicos para
cada paciente
crear órganos para cada persona que lo
necesita
estas tres ideas que suenan de ciencia
ficción tienen un punto en común
la tecnología de impresión 13
durante el último año del secundario
estando en la plaza y mirando lo que
cualquier adolescente mira en la playa
una nacional geographic es ahí que
encuentro un artículo sobre prótesis
mioeléctricas prótesis robóticas
comandadas por contracciones musculares
de entrada me pareció un desafío técnico
súper atractivo super interesante pero
investigando un poco más se encuentro
que también tenía un factor social un
impacto humano
y es porque ese tipo de prótesis aquí en
la argentina en ese momento eran de
difícil acceso
por sus elevados costos y porque
solamente eran importadas
es por eso que me embarco en el
desarrollo de una prótesis mioeléctrica
de miembro superior pero dentro del
marco de la filosofía del código abierto
donde todos los planos todos los
circuitos y todos los programas hoy son
de acceso libre y gratuito
si bien este tipo de prótesis presenta
resultados interesantes todavía
estábamos buscando una solución mecánica
para una necesidad biológica
en esa época empieza a entrar en auge
cada vez más esto de la impresión 3d
una tecnología de fabricación de
manufactura aditiva donde vamos
agregando material para crear una pieza
que previamente había sido diseñada en
la computadora
como si fuera una manga para decorar
torta que capa por capa va depositando
el material y convierte esa pieza que
era virtual en algo tangible en algo
real
tecnología que ha sido ampliamente
utilizada desde prototipos en
autopartistas pasando por casas de
tamaño real hasta hamburguesas
metiéndome un poco más encuentros sobre
la bio impresión impresión 3d pero ahora
con materiales biológicos con células
vivas
para crear órganos y tejidos como los
que todos nosotros tenemos ahora adentro
y ahora quiero que se tomen un segundo y
que me acompañan y que todos cierran los
ojos
quiero que inspiren profundo
y que toquen el dorso de la mano
que tratan de estirar la piel que
sientan el calor
el tacto
estamos trabajando para crear eso en una
vía impresora eso es la vídeo de
impresión
imagínense esa persona que está tratando
de explicar al agente de seguridad del
aeropuerto que la chicharra suena porque
tiene un implante de titanio
estamos cada vez más cerca de crear
piezas de reemplazo óseo
y cómo hacemos esto la vida impresión
que suena algo del primer mundo que
requiere inversiones millonarias
en nuestro caso fue con dos impresoras
viejas de oficina que conseguí que me
regalen un escáner y una disquetera y
fue con esos mecanismos que arme el
primer prototipo de vida impresora
con este prototipo me acerco a la
doctora mariana cidh de la facultad de
ingeniería quien ya venía trabajando en
el colágeno la proteína que funciona
como andamio de todos nuestros tejidos
material por excelencia para imprimir
estructuras biológicas
junto con ella empezamos a trabajar
sinérgicamente para poner a punto del
material y la tecnología potenciando nos
mutuamente
básicamente la dinámica de trabajo era
conseguir a los tendones regalados en la
carnicería de la esquina me los llevaba
a casa a escondidas de mi hermana que es
vegana
y escondidas
acompáñenme con esta escena sentado
frente al escritorio el vidrio que le
había sacado el escáner era mi mesa de
cirugía bisturí jeringas pinzas los
guantes puestos la lámpara de escritorio
y cortando con el cirujano
concentradísimo en mi operación es que
ahí al lado en un momento de abstracción
vio la almohada en la que dormía todas
las noches
en ese momento me di cuenta lo profundo
que me había metido en el proyecto como
me motivaba como me cautiva
más adelante empezamos a trabajar con
gastón galanter nick con quien
convertimos este proyecto de habitación
y un poco académico también en un
emprendimiento de base tecnológica
emprendimiento a partir del cual
empezamos a desarrollar nuevos modelos
de la impresora y trabajar con nuevos
institutos del conicet en aplicaciones
que ni se nos hubieran ocurrido
entre ellas impresión traje de
medicamentos cuando el doctor santiago
palma se nos acerca con este inquietud e
imprimir pastillas en 3-d primero nos
descolocó porque era algo que estaba muy
lejos de lo que veníamos haciendo
pero lo mismo investigamos empezamos a
buscar bibliografía y ahí encontramos la
visión que él tenía
encontramos que en el 2016 el año pasado
la sda que es como la anmat argentina
aprobó el primer medicamento impreso en
encontramos también que la geometría de
la pastilla que consumimos afecta en
cómo se libera el fármaco en el
organismo
no es lo mismo tomar una pastilla
esférica que una pastilla con forma de
cubo
y a su vez y aprovechando la tecnología
de impresión 3d teníamos la capacidad de
combinar distintos fármacos y materiales
de excipientes todos en la misma tableta
y con las dosis específicas que el
paciente necesita
todos conocemos a alguien que toma
cantidad de pastillas por día imagínense
comprimir todo eso en una tiramos el
pastillero de la abuela
por otro lado impresión 3d de órganos y
tejidos algo que suena de ciencia
ficción
y esta línea de aplicación en particular
busca resolver dos de las problemáticas
más importantes y el mayor impacto a la
hora de hacer un trasplante
por un lado
si logramos crear el órgano que el
paciente necesita ya no necesitamos un
donante específico nos desligamos de esa
lista de espera
por otro lado si ese órgano es creado
con las células del mismo paciente
disminuimos drásticamente la
probabilidad de rechazo
algunas de estas líneas de aplicación
toman provecho de los años y años de
evolución del organismo brindándole no
la solución completa sino un iniciador
un andamio como en el caso del hueso por
ejemplo se crea un andamio para que el
mismo organismo fabrique la solución que
necesita
y ahora si una solución biológica para
una necesidad biológica
han surgido nuevas aplicaciones desde
soluciones estéticas para pacientes
específicos o incluso impresión 3d de
tejidos pero en el espacio como va a ser
la nasa del año próximo
esta tecnología plantea desafíos e
inquietudes que algunos han sido
resueltos pero todavía siguen surgiendo
nuevos
entre ellos desde el punto de vista
ético que es lo que vamos a crear hasta
dónde vamos a llegar
desde el punto de vista regulatorio cuál
va a ser el organismo encargado de
regular esto y cómo le vas a
y desde el punto de vista de la
accesibilidad
como hacemos nosotros desarrolladores de
la tecnología para hacer que estas
soluciones lleguen a cada paciente que
lo necesita
los más de 20 mil argentinos y
argentinas que hoy están en lista de
espera o en proceso de inscripción para
recibir un órgano o tejido han sido y
siguen siendo el motor de este proyecto
proyecto que nos permitió ver la
importancia de la vinculación entre la
ciencia y la tecnología entre los
investigadores académicos y los
emprendimientos de base tecnológica
vinculación que permite avanzar sobre
las líneas de investigación o incluso
crear nuevas y expandir su alcance su
aplicación
es por eso que es crucial que sigamos
empujando y promoviendo la conexión
entre estos dos mundos que todavía
muchas veces parecen inconexos
pero este gran desafío tiene un factor
clave y es un factor cultural
y es la confianza en los desarrollos
argentinos
cuántos de nosotros hemos escuchado
hablar sobre la creatividad de los
argentinos de esa capacidad de
solucionar todos los problemas que
surgen con los recursos de los que
dispone incluso si el único recurso es
un alambre
pero cuántos de nosotros hemos escuchado
también
es productos de fabricación nacional
como sinónimo de más baratos y en menor
calidad que el extranjero
consolidemos esa confianza en los
desarrollos argentinos hagamos propia
esa creatividad
y nuevos
[Aplausos]
[Música]